this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you for that warm welcome it's a
real pleasure to be here and I really
want to thank Cornell University for
helping to bring all of us together for
this really important conversation
I really have four points I want to make
I'm talking about healthy soil I from
the American Farmland trust perspective
healthy soil it is I've an asset with
public and so the healthy soil is vital
to farm productivity the resilience of
farmers to severe weather but there are
tremendous public benefits that we've
heard from many of our speakers this
morning that come from healthy soil
slowly connected to our ability to grow
food our ability to have clean water and
an ability to have a healthy climate to
exist in so that's point number one I'll
point number two I think when we talk
about healthy soil we need to think
about that holistically and from the
American Farmland trust perspective the
foundation of that conversation is to
keep our most productive versatile and
resilient soil in farming ie don't pave
it over don't cover it with concrete and
this is not an inconsequential issue for
the state of New York that we have paved
over the equivalent of five thousand
farms since the early 1980s so the
foundation of a conversation about
healthy soil is to protect that land and
keep it in farming to start and then you
can complement that with discussion many
of you focus on today about stewardship
those two things coming together is
really the foundation of a holistic
conversation about healthy soil I think
there's some valuable lessons that we
can learn from the state of California
on this approach the state of California
in 2015 began allocating funding from
their carbon market towards the
development of a strategic agricultural
land conservation program they have
subsequently allocated seventy million
dollars towards permanently protecting
farmland as a way of reducing
transportation related emissions in
essence if we keep people living in
cities more compactly we're going to
reduce transportation emissions and then
they've
also invested their carbon proceeds and
healthy soils programs that invest in
research and technical assistance to
farmers with the stewardship of that
land I think there's some really
valuable lessons that we can learn from
California last year the American
Farmland trust released research report
called greener fields this is a report
that was largely based on data that I've
been gathered by the Department of
Environmental Conservation looked at
greenhouse gas emissions from
agricultural land compared to developed
land in new york and we found that the
average acre of farmland in new york
emitted 66 times fewer greenhouse gas
emissions than an acre of developed land
and that if we could reduce our mission
or the amount of farmland that we pave
over by 80 percent by 2050 it could have
the equivalent effect of taking a
million cars off the road in new york
who wouldn't want to see a million cars
off the road in new york so we think
that there's some valuable lessons that
we can as a community and as a state
think about for agricultural land as
we're thinking about our state's climate
strategy and that we absolutely should
have a really robust agricultural lands
component of our climate agenda so
that's point number two point number
three it was great to go after Don and
Dave and John Paul because I think one
of the lessons that I really took away
from that is how they are adapting and
learning and applying some common
practices but they have to be customized
to their situation and they need to be
customized because of the crops they're
producing the landscape in which they're
producing also management capacity is
very much an integral part of the
conversation so we've been really
excited over the last several years the
American Farmland trust has worked with
Cornell Cooperative Extension and soil
and water districts and others host more
than a dozen on-farm demonstrations in
Long Island in western New York as well
as five swell health field days mat bar
next to a health field day on Long
Island coming up Debbie
August 16th we think that those types of
on-farm in field really applied
conversations are really critical to
catalyzing this soil health movement in
New York um and to build on that we are
very excited a few weeks ago we
announced a new program with Cornell
University with NRCS with the Department
of Agriculture markets and others a
program called the practical soil health
specialists of New York it is a
professional development program that is
going to occur over the next two years
and we are looking to develop a network
of 20 practical soil health specialists
these are people in the public sector or
the private sector that really want to
provide training and technical
assistance to farmers and using soil
health practices successfully so it's a
very field based training program
applications for that program are due
Friday so if you are interested we've
had a tremendous result already response
already but it is an exciting program
there are flyers in the back and let's
see just tonight where are you Jeff
Jeff's got his hand raised in the back
if you want to learn more about that
program I talked to Jeff Ward a yearand
wrist ow at Cornell the last point I'm
gonna make is that when we talk about
soil health we need to think about
healthy soil not adjust on farmer owned
farm lands but on the land that farmers
rent as well just about 20% of our land
in New York is rented land often that
can be the most challenging land to get
conservation practices adopted on this
land owners are increasingly removed
from the farm and may not know as much
about production practices and farmers
may not feel like they have the Economic
Security to really invest in these
practices that have a longer return life
so we are really excited to be working
with Cornell Cooperative Extension at
Wyoming County and other partners to
pilot some trainings technical
assistance and communications activities
are gated towards women landowners as
well as farmers in the Genesee River
watershed and we've been doing that for
the last two years
experimenting with some different
approaches over the next year we're
going to be sharing our results in what
we're learning about really think that
that is an important part of this
conversation that's often overlooked
because it's not just the farmer owned
land that rental land is a really
important piece of this conversation so
I get just want to close that this is a
really important conversation and it's
not a conversation though just for
farmers it's with farmers but really
this is a conversation for all New
Yorkers because you know for all of us
eaters all of us that are thinking about
the water we want to drink or the water
we want to swim in in the health of our
this is a conversation that's relevant
allmusic's so thank you very much this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu